sofía bonilla desde hace algún tiempo
usted se ha interesado por el tema de la
sostenibilidad de la alimentación de los
animales sobre todo a partir de una
preocupación suya en lo que tenía que
ver con el desperdicio de comida si bien
entiendo puede explicarnos un poco esta
idea cómo es que surge su inquietud
sobre el tema y claro
pues estaba haciendo mi doctorado y
estaba buscando biomoléculas para
diferentes aplicaciones y obviamente
necesitábamos biomoléculas que fueran
económicas y ahí como que hizo el clic
de donde las podíamos buscar y esa era
el desecho de alimentos y cuando empecé
a cómo aprender más y a entender la
dimensión de la cantidad que se
desperdiciaba mí me pareció chocante
porque por un lado
hay gente que se muere de hambre sabemos
que en el futuro va a haber límites en
cuanto a los recursos que tenemos y por
este otro lado estamos desperdiciando
millones de toneladas de comida entonces
ahí como que dije
este es un problema muy grande necesita
una solución y como que esa idea quedo
en mi mente y cuando te dice que estaba
buscando biomoléculas porque para qué
sirve bueno esa es una historia un poco
más larga pero pueda tratar de resumir
la en mi doctorado yo estaba utilizando
proteínas para mejorar la separación
líquido sólido del desecho de aguas de
tratamiento e industrial
entonces ahí utilizamos proteínas que
conocíamos pero al mismo tiempo
queríamos buscaron una mejor opción y
que fuera más económica y entonces
estamos buscando ese tipo de proteínas
en desechos
y además usted se ha especializado
también en el tema de las proteínas que
pueden ser si bien entiendo sustitutos
de la carne es así si entonces ahí ya es
unos años después terminé mi doctorado y
me gustó la idea de la economía circular
todo empezó con esa y con ese problema
de desecho de comidas y la economía
circular pues era una solución a ese
problema si tuviéramos la oportunidad de
utilizar todos los desechos que existen
para producir cosas que utilizamos en
nuestra vida diaria podríamos mejorar la
situación actual de muchos recursos
entonces terminé mi doctorado y me
dediqué a trabajar con algas primero a
canadá y después me canto una beca y me
fui para holanda a trabajar con un grupo
de investigación que tiene mucha
experiencia en esa área
y ahí fue cuando empecé realmente a
conocer como el potencial que tenían las
algas y las proteínas alternativas para
reemplazar muchas aplicaciones de lo que
ahorita se usa con productos animales
incluyendo la carne
ahora como usted dice de haga de
proteínas alternativas creo que ahí es
donde entra en el juego las proteínas
animales e insectos mejor dicho que si
no me equivoco como que se llega a los
insectos y vamos a aclarar con usted
inicia este trabajo y el material que yo
leí hace unos días atrás hablaba de los
insectos y su relación con la
alimentación animal no es que usted está
proponiendo ni mucho menos a los
insectos mientras mira las mascotas no
es sí entonces a eso las proteínas de
insectos llegaron pues por mi interés
general en las proteínas alternativas y
en la en holanda cuando estaban hablando
haciendo mi doctorado viene una compañía
que se llama pro tics y tenían estaba
montando una planta muy muy grande de
insectos y cuando empecé a entender más
como la calidad de la proteína el perfil
de minoración de la proteína era
evidente
que era muy parecido a la carne y
entonces si existía esta opción de
insectos que es mucho más sostenible
utiliza hasta darnos cien veces menos
los recursos que normalmente utilizamos
porque no y entonces ahí como que nació
mi interés en en los insectos y es como
mencionando es que vamos a [ __ ] los
insectos volando y hacerlos a las
mascotas sino hay ciertos procesos y
plantas en escala grande en donde se
pueden extraer las proteínas o se hace
harina de insectos y en él hay muchas
compañías ahora trabajando en denso
entonces podemos tengo la oportunidad de
utilizar ese avance para avanzar a otras
áreas como la comida mascotas
el material que estoy viendo y no soy un
entendido del tema puedo cometer un
error en la interpretación habla de que
el trabajo avanzó más en el sentido de
utilizar esas proteínas
derivadas de los insectos para la
alimentación de perros y las proteínas
obtenidas a partir de algas para la
alimentación de gatos es esta diferencia
así en todo caso si es así porque no es
tan clara la diferencia pero estás
correcta en que la primera línea que
estamos planeando es para perros y está
enfocada en
y proteínas además de insectos
porque las dos la proteína de los
insectos tiene todos los aminoácidos que
los perros reses y los gatos tienen unos
requerimientos de nutrición un poco
diferentes y la proteína de insectos
tiene el 95% de los aminoácidos que
necesitan los gatos pero falta ese 5% y
para eso estamos utilizando algas es la
única manera
es posible darle todos los nutrientes a
un gato sin productos animales como de
carne de huevo de pescado
sin utilizar suplementos sintéticos y
tenemos una patente provisional una
aplicación de una patente provisional
para utilizar estos ingredientes de
algas que son completamente nuevos en el
mercado sabemos que la alimentación a
partir de fuentes naturales como los
insectos forman parte de la alimentación
tradicional en algunas culturas incluso
humanas y en occidente esto es mucho más
raro por supuesto crees que es factible
que el público acepte que la
alimentación de formas cosas parte de
estas fuentes los insectos y las algas
eso es esa es una muy buena pregunta y
en realidad vemos que hay compañías que
están utilizando proteínas de insectos
en otros países en europa hay ya varias
compañías incluso recientemente purina
decidió lanzar una una comida de perros
con harina de insectos una pequeña
proporción yo creo que el mundo está
dispuesto a cambiar
la tradición de cómo hacemos las cosas
por cosas mejores y eso es lo que
estamos proponiendo una mejor manera de
alimentar a nuestras mascotas
que es sostenible porque en 100 años
simplemente no va a haber acceso a los
proteínas que estamos utilizando ahora
que es que tienen de de de vaca a pollo
o carne van a ser mucho más escasas y
desde el punto de vista sanitario hay
alguna ventaja en este tipo de
alimentación
si además además el insecto que estamos
utilizando es una es una mosca se llama
mosca negra
y la mosca negra soldado es como la
traducción en español y este insecto
tiene propiedades antibióticas también
entonces si tú lo comparas con el pollo
que tiene salmonela o con la carne que
tiene otros patógenos eso es algo que no
viene con los insectos entonces también
tiene esa ventaja
sofía tú no te quedas tener una mera
investigación y me ha dicho con todo el
respeto porque deposita la investigación
requiere un grandísimo esfuerzo pero
además decidiste avanzar e iniciar tu
propio proyecto en este sentido de qué
se trata si entonces la verdad como que
por los últimos años yo me daba cuenta
en el laboratorio que habían muchísimas
ideas muy innovadoras muy buenas que se
quedaban en el laboratorio porque no
había no hay como ese puente de la
laboratorio a industria y como que
siempre estuve pendiente como de esa
oportunidad para crear un impacto
positivo y lo sentí cuando empecé a
trabajar con la idea de los insectos y
las algas y
voy a poner más cuotas entonces hace más
de un año empecé home & fit y ese es el
start up en el que estoy trabajando
ahora estamos dedicados a cómo crear la
mejor comida de mascotas utilizando la
ciencia que está disponible y la
'sostenibilidad como nuestra guía para
hacer los mejores productos posibles y
en qué estadio se encuentra este
desarrollo está pronto a poder ser
comercializado y tener una etapa de
investigación y está en una etapa de
ensayo de qué se trata de cómo de cómo
como puede ser estadio de estadística en
este momento sí claro el estamos en los
últimos pasos del desarrollo de la
comida para para perros
vamos tenemos como agendada la prueba
piloto donde vamos a producir 250
kilogramos de comida vamos a hacer los
últimos tests que tengamos que hacer
para garantizar que la nutrición está en
el estándar que nosotros queremos y que
nuestros perros obviamente les encanta
la comida porque es importante es muy
importante que les
así que el factor número uno entonces
una vez pase la prueba piloto ya estamos
listos para lanzar ya tenemos todo el
resto de la cadena de abastecimiento
organizada entonces por covite hemos
estado un poco atrasados pero esperamos
que en abril de este año estemos listos
para sacar la comida para para pérez lo
cual es un plazo muy breve falta muy
poco para el medio abrir estamos ya en
la segunda etapa la segunda mitad perdón
de febrero y en vistas entonces a esta
nueva etapa en tu proyecto si tuvieras
que convencer al público de que el
producto que van a ofrecer a partir de
tu investigación es mejor que la comida
tradicional si tuvieras que convencer al
usuario de que tiene que cambiar la
forma de alimentar a sus mascotas puede
ser argumentos que utilizarían
hay varios como yo lo veo hay tres tres
tipos de ventajas que el tipo de comida
que nosotros ofrecemos le da a los
usuarios la primera es la nutrición con
la oportunidad de utilizar proteínas
alternativas podemos crear diseñar la
proteína perfecta sabemos que las
mascotas tienen necesidades por ciertos
aminoácidos cierto perfil de aminoácidos
y mezclando estas diferentes fuentes de
proteínas podemos crear ese perfil
entonces nutrición excepcional la
segunda es la parte de la sostenibilidad
y es la realidad que tenemos que reducir
nuestro impacto ambiental de muchas
maneras y cambiar la comida de nuestros
perros en realidad es algo que podemos
hacer que es pequeño pero tiene un
impacto gigante el 25 por ciento de la
carne en norteamérica termina en comida
para perros imagínate es un nombre es un
número gigante
y el tercero es que ofrecemos un
producto que esté libre de crueldad no
sabemos que las prácticas enlace en las
fincas donde crean estos productos no
están en el mejor estándar y la
oportunidad de poder darle a los
consumidores algo que ellos quieren
por su amor por los animales no es estar
alineados con sus valores esas son las
ventajas
sofía bonilla muchísimas gracias por tu
entrevista al contrario canadá
internacional y mucha suerte entonces
con este emprendimiento
muchas gracias luis